the greatest hack of all time whether
it's bodybuilding or business is getting
with people who are far ahead of you
almost all of the periods of my life
where I had huge changes or improvements
in my physique was when I had people who
were better than me giving me Insight
you go more wide just like this and more
wide you're going to be more both to
fill all this part that's what we're
doing if someone has a decade of
experience on something they have more
context to give you advice which is why
I tried to buy any experience I can from
anybody who's willing to sell it to me
I'd rather get the lesson without the
scar that's why you got to listen to
Pros baby